然后美股其实走了一个all time high
这个是最近以来其实怎么说呢
冲了蛮高的 也有点出乎我意料的
就是我之前就我们说美股之前为什么一个
就四月份的一个下跌
其实有三件事情联合在一起
一方面是特朗普的policy
就是这个给到市场一个认为叫为不风险tell risk
这个我们年初的时候一直提到
可能会发生tell risk
然后tell risk发进展会怎么样
这个事情非常不确定
那么第二方面呢
其实因为美国的tell risk和特朗普政策
大家开始定价川普的一些负面东西
使得市场我们叫end of US exceptionism
就是结束了美国一个特殊的
特殊的那个投资地位
大家觉得美国特殊投资地位中间最重要的就是AI
大家觉得因为美国特朗普的政策
包括特朗普政策
使得美国公司对于全球的这个覆盖影响会减少
那么这些东西会结束美国的特殊性
那么美国特殊性结束
第二个最惨其实是AI
那么在那个时候
其实我们当时提到过一个想法
就是说整个市场不确定性还是很大的
但是在这个中间其实美国的exceptionism
美国的特殊性没有取消
也就是说美国在AI方面和科技方面的
它的这个优势
不管特朗普现在短期里面做什么东西
都很难被动摇
所以特别是业绩吧
我们当时讲到是25年的业绩
或者是25年延出到26年的这个业绩
其实美国业绩就科技公司
大公司Mega7和半导体
他们的业绩都不会特别差
特别是半导体
另外这个东西的确定性是很强的
那么第三个事情使得前一段时间的波动
和下跌的每次Dip的原因
市场还同时在定价10年期国债的5%
那么这中间包括了对于美国财政的一些
美国财政之处的一些担心
对于特朗普出了big beautiful bill之后
对于美国财政的担心
对于国债供应的一些担心
对于美国货币的一些担心
那么这件事情我们其实从开始
就完全把它剃除掉
我一直入out说美国国债是不会跌到百分之五的
对吧
然后美国也不会有货币问题
但是确实我对于Trump的Telrace估计
可能会比较更加严重一点
以至我其实在下跌的时候
也没有加强也没有减强
那么手上一直持有的也是AI和半导体的公司
什么现在这个位置
我觉得还是我上两周讲
就是对于美国来说
我觉得还是上两周讲
第一呢就是是一个非常难以去做短期操作市场
首先现在任何负面的消息对市场影响没有那么大
你可以看到各种各样负面消息
但是不是很能打得动市场了
就是看到最近的这个气势不是很能打得动
那么所以做空是很难的
你即使觉得有些负面的影响
除非你说美国明天跟中国又开始告白了
对吧
那么我个人觉得这个在Telrace上面
再出这样大的问题可能没有那么大
但是其他的一些事情对美股来说
就短期里做空是很难的
因为负面消息打不太动
那么同时的话呢
它偏贵
你就是说我们现在看美股的投资来看
先要看它的Position
就多少人在里面
然后多少人在外面
我觉得Hatch放头穿大概70%左右
然后整体市场大概60%左右
就6成的我们做仓位如果out of 10的话
大概Position在out of 6
out of 6中间有几股力量可能还在继续买
第一个就是CTA
我今天没有把CTA的图抛出来
但CTA上下涨的买
跌了卖上下基本上是Even的
那么我晚一点可以Post代表说我推的什么
然后CTA基本上是吃
就是CTA还是有买盘的力量
因为一方面CTA这段时间一直在买
同时的话最近Vol is在下涨
所以我们叫Systematic Position里面
包括Vol Control和CTA
Vol Control就是当Vol降低它就买
所以Vol Control后面还有一段的买盘
然后再加上就是这段时间
可能会有些Blackout
然后过了一些业绩以后
公司的回购还是会继续的
所以这一些是Position上来说
我们认为是6 out of 10
并不是特别差
但是固执上是觉得高的
现在固执上对于现在的经济状态来说
固执肯定是挺高的
就说我们我认为后面
其实市场上也有很多Position在等
就跟我的态度很像
就是大家觉得有一些
对于基本面看法来说
他们会觉得到年底的时候
我们会看到Unemployment到4.6到4.7
超过4.5
这个可能性很大
我也觉得可能性很大
所以有一些投存在外面等
那么这个事情
其实基本上还看自己判断的
因为如果说这件事情没有发生
没有发生有可能这部分钱里面
中间一部分又反杀回去了
就又杀回这个市场面去
我是觉得今年是一个terrorist的年份
但现在从4月份到现在
为什么长这么多
本质上是大家觉得terrorist这些
这个尾部的风险变得更小了
没有那么大了
然后觉得AI特别是
Microsoft的业绩出来以后
大家觉得AI这个
这个其实对于行内的话
大家还是本来就没有觉得
美国的特殊性会被取消的
大家觉得有exceptionism
特别是AI这个故事还继续在
那么加上最近也没有人再会拒绝的
美国十年期国在再会冲到5%了
所以这些东西利好因素
得加在一起就把它冲高了
那真正业绩如果说
N-POM到了4.64.7
我觉得现在的估值肯定是偏高的
就是现在这个估值的水平是偏高
但是这中间的还是有区分的
就是我仍然觉得现在很多的半导体的
公司半导体AI的公司并不算很滚
如果你把时间拉长来说的话
并不是很滚
美国的exceptionism肯定是在的
但是在大部分公司来看是偏贵的
所以这个就是现在我觉得市场
一个基调大致的状态
但是这个中间很多的
因为我们有这么一个总统
有这么一个总统
他其实本质上他做两件事情
第一个他要面子
第二个他说外行管理行
他很多事情都是外行管理行
所以这个过程里面
很多的不确定性和这个tell risk
我觉得还是过程当中
在这个位置上我是不会加仓
就是我既然跌下来也没有减仓
涨上去也没有加仓
在这个位置上更加不可能加仓
那个哪怕是半导体
我觉得我也不太会去加仓
因为网上的这个空间和
就我们叫做性价比吧
网上的性价比其实没有那么高
就是哪怕我们错过了
今年四季度
四季度真的业绩
真的这个经济基本面没有变差
然后呢
那个等着基本面变差那些投资人
又杀进去把他冲得更高了
那么也要坚持住
既然没有加就不要加
要不你就加就国当加
要没有加的话
我我的建议是不用走
就等着看
因为这个市场终究晒
那个volatility就波动
上上下下之后
他会去一个更加明确的方向
如果就是经济基本面
给你一个更加明确的趋势以后
那我们再看
就是等到估值更加
我觉得更加合理之后再看
那么川普呢特朗普呢
这个人就上周
其实有很多的事情
都是跟特朗普是相关的
那上周的时候
我们讲过这个美国和伊朗的问题
周末的时候
我听了一个原来mi6的
就是英国军情处的
这个agent一个特工
然后他现在被高盛请为
那个political economist
然后他分享了一下
就关于那个伊朗的一个一个看法
因为毕竟那个美国几个炸弹
炸下去以后呢
那个核泄漏是没有发生的
所以呢
他的核原料是肯定运掉了
就两种可能
核原料要么就运掉
要么呢就是把那个
基地给没有完全摧毁
就是要么没炸到
要么就是运掉了
反正伊朗40公斤的
那个60%纯度的核原料
肯定现在在伊朗人手上
所以关于伊朗核危机的事情呢
就是他去发表一下自己的看法
就是那个
叫Alex吧
就mi6发表一下看法
但是他是讲到了
他是相对于是比较正面
他讲两方面的就是看法
主要影响
一方面是对于伊朗
其实另外一方面是对于中国的
所以他讲到这两方面影响
就第一呢
就是他觉得那个特朗普
强势的要求伊朗去
去和平
这件事情大概率是会完成的
就哈密内伊在那个
最近发表了几次声明
然后呢
其实表他相当于相当于比较空洞
虽然他对于那个
川普就美国提出
华盛顿方面提出的这个
这个停火
就或者是后续的和平
他没有接受
被美国毕竟炸了吗
他不敢直接接受
但是呢
他也不敢拒绝
他也没有拒绝
所有的声明相对来说比较轰动
那么中间有四方面的原因
他觉得就是最终伊朗
是会接受和这个解释
他相对来说比较乐观一点
就第一呢
就是伊朗在军事上是完败的
他在军事上对于那个
以色列是差一代
对美国是差两代
所以这次军事上完败了以后呢
那个伊朗的革命卫队
就是IRGC
就是他的那个
他的军事体制是两边分开的
革命卫队控制了很多经济上的
这个经济上的功能
就是他不但是军队
而且军队重伤
他是一个军阀形式的东西
他大概军费开始有一大半
到革命卫队去
但是这次革命卫队其实非常脆弱
就是他
革命卫队一下子被击垮了
所以他觉得军事上的革命卫队
其实受到很大的打击
包括他在政治上的影响力
都受到打击
那么在停火之后
其实以色列和伊朗互相
还忽视了不少的导弹
但是这个呢
他们认为不一定是来自于宗教
就是神棍们的
就是这个伊朗的神棍们的初衷
神棍们的其实对于这件事情
对于那个战争的后续
其实非常谨慎
因为他们躲在那个地下防空堡里面
非常害怕上面失控
那么是革命卫队非常就军方
就革命卫队方面
他们是希望能够获得
就是稍微赢回前面子
所以他再继续发一些导弹
在军事上实在是完版
第二呢就是俄国和中国
几乎把伊朗是抛弃了
他的他的他的big brother
把他给抛弃掉
特别是普京
他甚至希望用伊朗的利益
去交换很多他的乌克兰的利益
这个是比较确定的一件事情
然后第三呢就是
这个他们也没有很确定的
就是说
到底有没有把他比较
说离星集权给炸掉
如果说离星集是炸掉的话
那么他们认为
伊朗已经不可能再发展出核武器
因为不可能发展核武器
因为他要从60%的
那个油要
虽然他有400公斤的
这个纯度比较高的油燃料
但是要从60%到90%
他现在没有那些设施的情况下
不被美国和以色列打击的情况下
再要做出核武器
很难
再短期就很难
那么这个就回到
他们认为的一个疑点
就是这几个炸弹
到底有没有把伊朗的核设施给炸掉
因为伊朗也希望就是告诉美国
我承受了很大打击
你不要再打我了
那个特朗普不管打掉没有打掉
他为了他的野面
就是这个就是一个
相当于在美国
就创布这个人的问题
就是他为了自己的野面
他一定认为是打掉的
所以这个中间的真正的
true risk
这个是需要以色列去承担的
就是伊朗如果他的核设
是没有被打掉
那么现在原子能机构
已经没有办法监测了
那他就要悄悄地把这个核武器给搞出来
因为他需要搞出核武器
不难
那个以色列搞出核武器
他没有试验
他拿的是美国的残属
伊朗完全可以拿朝鲜的残属
朝鲜我相信
朝鲜和俄国的残属
他可能也有
他不一定需要去核测试
去做出这核武器
所以
这个他们认为是一个
一个比较大的true risk
就为大风险
但是假设他的核设施
如果被打掉的话
伊朗应该是没有能力做出核武器的
所以对于大部分情况
就他们认为
就是现在这个事情
没有那么容易判断了
包括CNN的
CNN提出一个看法
那个特朗普狂骂那个记者
就是说到伊朗可能
没有被摧毁那么严重
那么这个事情被特朗普狂骂
但是从MI6那位Alex的角度来看
他认为是相对来说比较乐观的
而且这一次
其实打击到了IRGC
就是革命卫队的这个在国内的微信
所以有可能在伊朗的政权方面
就是神棍政权
他们认为更加对内
或者是甚至进行一部分的改革
就是那个对于那个
革命卫队的力量削弱以后
可能会甚至来说
接受一部分的就改革的力量
进入这个政府层面
那么他们认为在伊朗内部
就是伊朗可能会终止
革命输出性的
因为革命卫队
这IRGC就是输出性革命
包括野门
包括那个很多藩以色的势力
都是伊朗支持的
它可能会减少
就是伊斯兰的这个力量的输出
但他们会支持一个比较大的
就是乐观的看法
那么伊朗事件第二个影响的
就是Alex认为是对于中国
因为你包括这次看到
川普在那个NATO CEMET上面
他是非常非常自信的
他甚至用到了这样子
就是你两个小孩打架
让他们打两三分钟
他是指伊朗和那个以色列
然后人家说那你就是爸爸
他说对
就是我就是爸爸
就是意思
就是爸爸告诉你们
停 不要打了
他的态度非常高高在上
然后对于NATO
甚至这次因为美国的主导
NATO就是北约他的文件
对于乌克兰的事情是一笔大国
对于中国也不一定会指名到行
因为这个要符合特朗普的一些
他的就是自负的一些外交的政策
所以但是NATO这次基本上是
除了西班牙以外
那个基本上是满足了美国要求
他们把军费增加到5%的要求
就是这一次把军费在10年里面
欧洲各国要把房屋的开支
闯现在打开2%
很多的2%都不到
要增加到5%
5%就相当于现在波兰的水平
波兰都没有到5%
那么中间3.5是直接的军费支出
然后1.5是基础设施
包括艺术设施
是要你遭到公路
就只要跟房屋相关
它都能算
所以这个就是欧洲的重新武装
这个如果是达到的话
那未来10年里面军费的开支
会非常非常大
所以房屋的公司可以去关注
那么这个也是特朗普要求的
就这个其实一方面就是德国
其实有主动性
想去增加房屋的开支
让欧洲增加房屋开支
第二方面就是美国的一个全球影响力上
就是它不愿意
承担全球上很多的这个责任
但是伊朗这件事情
在对于中国的影响是
中国可能误判了
就是美国对全球事务的
一个插手的这个主动性
就是中国以前认为美国完全脱手
然后就是它需要全球方面收缩
中国它全球的GDP在全球的比率在下降
它的人口或者它的这个制造业
都不支持它能够在
像50年代60年代70年代这样的全球输出
那么中国认为就是在
包括在台湾问题和东南亚很多问题上
美国会帅会退
但是伊朗的这个美国这次丢了炸弹以后
可能会让中国重新去思考
美国在全球方面的输出
它是联合盟友继续去
联合盟友继续去有全球的布局
还是说真正的是后退
所以他认为就是两方面
就是Alex的认为
就是说第一方面是伊朗可能会减少
就是伊斯兰的输出
第二呢
就是中国对于美国的判断
可能要重新进行判断
那么这个是伊朗的一个问题
那么伊朗对于油价的影响
其实很明显
就油价们跌下来
那么后续的油价会怎么样呢
我认为后续的油价涨不太上去
第一呢
就是现在油价上还定价了几个刀了
大概我们之前大概有15美元左右的
Risk premium
现在大概有几个美元的Risk premium
那么伊朗和以色列的问题
继续Escalate很难了
就是这件事情在伊朗层面被炸了
如果说真的炸到了
他就要演绩西谷了
如果没有炸到他也要演绩西谷
他要继续悄悄地保护靠核武器
所以他没有任何动力继续搞
现在美国对于内塔尼亚湖的影响力是很大
所以以色列确实是想灭自朝狄
就把他直接搞死
但是美国按着他他也干不了事
所以伊朗和以色列的问题
我觉得从短期里面就是差不多要结束了
所以市场也是这么定价的
那么在过去几个月里面
因为中东的问题的问题在Escalate
在变得更加严峻
就不是直接打的时候
这打之前其实就开始
我们会看到全球在过度储备
美国没有
除了美国之外
全球都在过度储备
大概1.3个million per barrel
1.3
1.3个million 130万桶每天
这样的在增加
所以在过去一段时间的储备在增加的
然后de-escalate
就是这个危机在慢慢解除之后
那么OPEC在8月份之前
可能还会增加一个million
一百万左右的桶的供应
那么你就看到全球的供应来说是供应过度的
包括美国
我一直觉得美国经济
unemployment的数据会变得更差
所以全球就是unemployment数据
会变更差这种情况下面
我认为油是供应过度的
这和黄金是不一样
黄金你可以做一个四位
大概上次他们做了一个四位
百分之有70多家央行
认为我要增加黄金储备
但是没有央行认为我要减少黄金储备
所以黄金的趋势
就是央行大家有没有意愿去买
那么这个趋势和油是完全不一样
油是要供需的
所以8月份走路
7月份8月份之后
它的需求在减少
所以对油不是很看好的
这个是我的个人一个看法
然后我今天放的这个图是这个方面
其实大家也能够想到
就是我讲一下
那个Trump和Fed的问题没有关系
其实特朗普和那个
特朗普和那个杰炮
就是他骂了杰炮
他说中国
他说美国现在利息应该降到1%
为什么美联储现在还不降息
这就前两天的事情
然后那个对于联储
其实这个是对于联储上一次声明
就杰炮讲到我为什么没有降息
因为tariff
他其实并没有针对特朗普
但是特朗普这个人非常要面子
他觉得面子被攻击了
所以他就反过来去攻击杰炮
说你没有降息
那么其实联储对于
我上次讲到联储对于关税的这个影响
是放在一个非常谨慎的位置
就是就没有高估关税的影响
他相当来说比较谨慎的位置
那么但是呢
现在特朗普头上面临两个大的危机
就是他都要去解决
特朗普面临到了
就是国内的一些危机
或者是挑战的时候
他习惯性就怪到别人头上去
他现在要最重要的一件事情
他过他的Big Beautiful Bill
就是大美利法案
那么这个法案940页里面
包括了很多东西
包括了TaxCut
他包括他减少Medicare
包括了他给更多的预算
给那个immigration
就是那个移民控制移民
那么包括了他减少那个SNAP实务券
这些东西都在他的Big Beautiful Bill
他本来是希望4月7月份
要在那个国庆假日时候要去签字
要过这个议会
那么包括你可以看得到
在那个Elon Musk也去攻击这个东西
认为他是在挣心美国
叫我们叫传统产业
就是不可能挣心的制造业
但是对于星星科技的投入不够多
那么其实就是特朗普
借这个机会就爆破下一轮了
那么这个法案受到很多的阻碍
这个阻碍中间在共和党内部的阻碍
就是他的赤字过多了
就是你以前一直去说那个白人的赤字过多
你自己搞了一个这么大赤字
所以这个赤字
他用什么方法去说我这个赤字会减少呢
他就就怪到了杰炮
说连储没有降息
所以我的利息支出太高了
他是希望把利息支出这部分
再去算到我的赤字减少里面去
我其实赤字可以减少更多的
因为你的利息过高了
他的责任都是永远挂到别人头上的
但是他提到了
要把利息降到1%
然后要发很多的短债
我待会先说一下
这个事情是非常非常不靠谱的
因为你把利息如果降到1%
然后发很多短债
短债就等于现金
他对于通胀的破坏是极大的
美国现在就是发那个bills
就发那个短债
他控制在一般来说
概率是控制在20%左右
这个for good reason
就是你一旦发很多很多的债
你债的供应量变大
美国债不可能卖不出去
对于债的供应量变大的结果
就是枯棒棒的价格会上升
而且枯棒棒的价格
就是供应会变大
它的利率会上升
所以长端债务的利率上升之后
它会反过来压制你的风险市场
就是你的股票包括股票倒还好
因为你的支出变大以后
很多公司的业绩会变得很好
包括Microsoft的中间有很多业绩
都是都是政府层面
但是对于像黄金比特币
或者这些我们叫做资产类别
非盈利性资产类别
它的影响就会比较大
它反过来可能可以压制小通涨
但是如果你发很多短债
你想在银行层面
就是我们叫Clado
就CSA里面Clado
比方说五年债
它的Hackers是8%
因为它价格会变化的
但是如果是Builds
它Hackers有0.5
Hackers就是我拿100块的Builds
我可以借99.5
但是我拿100块的枯棒
我只能借92
所以它的货币的乘速会大很多
如果说你现在发的全部是短债
你把20%的短债的这个东西给去掉
没问题
你可以发很多短债
但是立马这个短债就会压低
就是它会造成货币很大的犯了
Coupon发行的不够多
那么我钱有很多
那么要去买Coupon的人
就有可能会去买公司债
就对应的公司债
CDS的这个CDS bread会变少
CDS bread变少
就第二个反应就是股票乱涨
那股票乱涨之后
可能就是钱再会到其他的
这个各种各样的这个资产里面去
所以马上就可能会产生同仗
那么同时的话
就是说你不要觉得我发很多Builds
马上就是股票狂涨
然后资产资本市场很好
这个是会有个反效应的
因为一旦你发生發了Builds
你的利率下降以后
美元马上就是美元的估值会出问题
你会发觉就是
原来当rate上升的时候
利率上升的时候
钱都笼到美国去
因为它是结算货币
钱都过到美国去
US Exceptionism
US Exceptionism不光存在于AI上面
还存在于债势上面
利率市场上面
钱都要到美国去
当你利率下降
下降太快的话
那你的钱都会离开美国的
你的钱会被掏空
就是资金会流出
最终你的股票涨还是不涨
还不好说
比如说你短期里面可能涨一下
但是最终涨也不涨
不好说
会产生很多的混乱
那这个混乱发生什么样的情况
结果是怎么样
不可测的
因为没有人干过这个事情
没有人说我打破了20%的Builds发行
其实也论的时候
已经打破了20%的Builds发行
发到23了
但是你要说像特朗普讲的
全部发Builds
这个结果是怎么样
非常不可测
所以就说它的这个政策
有很强的不确定性
它为了过自己的Builds
过自己的那个Big BeautifulBuilds
它采取了很多的
就讲了这些话
那么Big BeautifulBuilds
现在最新的情况是怎么样的
我今天时间可能比较紧
当后我还讲两句稳定密的事情
就我讲快一点
就是Big BeautifulBuilds
这两天的Senate受到了很大影响
中间的就是
因为在那个参议院里面
它的这个投票是53
其实47
差3票
就有三个人判辩
那这个Builds就过不了了
现在明确的Tillis和那个可能
Mitch McConnell
那些人就可能会判辩
就是那个在参议院里面
Tillis已经
特朗普为了把这个Builds过掉
去威胁了参议院
就说你现在经验明年要再选
我共和党的经费可能会不给你
如果你不支持我这个Build
我就不给你
那Tillis说我明年不竞选
然后我还是要反对你
这个是共和党内部党
这是共和党内部的明确的一票
所以他未必够票能够马上过得去
这个是一个
这个是一个很大的变数
就是他那个Big BeautifulBuild
能不能过得掉
Tillis现在专心的要把这个东西给过得掉
我是认为经过修改以后
大概率它总是能过得掉
就是7月初他过不了到7月底
他应该也是能过得掉
但是就是在这两天里面很难用
现在这个Build马上闯关过门
很难了
因为他在党
就是在那个党内
在那个参议院里面的反对
反对票还是比较多
那么这个市场后面的就是
我觉得几个观察点
就是第一个呢
就是我觉得第一个
美联储不太会受特朗普的威胁
在J-PAL的这个态度上面
狗们虽然预期降息点四到三次
我觉得今年就是一次
今年最多降一次
J-PAL肯定定住不会动了
因为通账什么样的情况
不清楚
这个是大家觉得通账有多少会被
就是business
就是公司会多少程度上把这个通账
去加到consumer
就是消费者头上
这个基本上大家认为
一个月里面百分之五十
然后但是时间越长越多的这个
就是tariff
这个关税会被加到消费者头上
所以通账我觉得可能在暑假的时候
还是会太多
还是会增加一些
所以连储看着这个东西
就而且经济现在没有明确的有
比方说到
失业率到4.6 4.7的症状
那么我认为连储不太会动
市场现在定价非常像去年7月份8月份
就是我们认为是一个好的经济变弱
美联储会进行降息
非常像去年的那个6月份7月份
去年6月7月份的时候
那个时候sci-co
我们就认为这个sci-co stock
就是周期性的股票比防御性股票
表现好很多
对吧
但是最后美联储并没有像这样
最后美联储其实
那个降息的幅度比大家低
那个sci-co stock有调整过来
现在sci-co stock versus
现在sci-co stock versus defensive stock
就是那个防御性的股票
这个差价又可去年
其实7月份说很像
所以我觉得其实
市场就是觉得现在经济数据
正好不温不火了
就是到了这个正好的时候
觉得那个美联储会cut into ok growth
我觉得现在整个从宏观层面
也太乐观
从固执层面也是太乐观
但是AI的半导体的公司
长端是没有问题的
就是它的盈利和各方面是没有问题
我选个三五分钟
我讲一下那个刚刚有提到
关于稳定币的事情
我觉得稳定币这个东西
对于有很多人说
稳定币这个东西是用来买美国的
或者是来补充美国这个
买美债补充美债的这个需求不足
我觉得不是
完全不存在
第一呢
稳定币的法案通过之后
它这个钱
它是只能够去买短借债券
对
然后就说那个真正的那个
他买的是
相当于是买的是短债
就是那个
我们说稳定币法案
他拿了7个USD去买的是短债
所以对那个整个国债市场
是没有影响
有影响的是那个ESL
ESL大解绑大概是在
2万亿美元左右
2万亿美元
然后这个流动性进入到这个库庞市场
库庞市场22万亿
但是这个22万亿里面
真正市场叫我们叫free tradeable
可交易的
大概只有10万亿
所以这个对美国债券的影响是很大的
就是我们根本不用去担心
就说美国发债发不掉
不可能的事情
他把银行资本
你稍微释放出来一点点
这个全部能够解决
但是稳定币这东西
真正的影响就是在哪里呢
就说他真正是一个什么东西
他是一个
我们认为是一个Money market
是一个货币市场
就说我本来这些U和美元
他拿过来去买了这个国债
或者是他监管就表示USDT
他的这个钱买了什么东西
你不确定的
最后能不能对付也是不知道的
所以我等于是把U
可以把它变成美元
一比一的可以兑换
加一个桥梁
然后让它变成
就比方说你把USDT当成美元
把它变成了一个叫Money market
就是货币市场基金
但是差别是在
这个货币市场基金
包括Circle搞的货币市场基金
这个钱买成美国国债券后的利息
是不给到USDT的owner
因为他是稳定币
稳定币他没有吃到直接的利息
所以当他没有吃到这个5%的利息的时候
真正的Circle的利益
就是在于他变成了一个货币市场基金
但是这个货币市场基金
又不把收益给到投资人
给他自己拿走了
所以他的收益是在这一块
这个是他的收益
但是你说
因为我做了稳定币法案
然后Crypto就去快炼市场
或者去快炼这个资金
对于市场会有什么影响
对于宏观市场有什么影响
影响是零
没有任何影响
那么这个东西对于币权市场有什么影响
我觉得也没有什么影响
就是除非你说能够更快的
更容易的把美元的资金变成USDT
但是把美元资金变成USDT
原来变成USDT或USDC
原来换U的渠道
比方说你在太大开户
或者你在社会开户
你开户的KYC要求和现代KYC要求
没有变化
所以你本来的话
现在的话
还是的话
我不认为
就现在这个阶段
就是稳定币法案通过以后
会真正的对去快炼市场造成
比方说大规模资金涌入
然后有很多山寨集
我觉得不会
基本上还是不太会
那包括稳定币法案
你说现在推出很多美股上炼
对于美股有什么影响
我觉得影响也是零
因为你去快炼市场就这么点钱
你这点钱
真正这里面的钱
其实这里面前
你可以认为去快炼大部分的
做山寨币的投资人
都是赌徒
他是要去赌钱
他赌100倍的
他买彩票去的
他买Navillian
他不会拿美元买
就是真正的币圈的投资人
对于美股的需求没有那么大
RWA的需求也没有那么大
就他们这个
还是一个完全不同的投资圈
你要把币圈要带起来
你得有更多的赌徒
就真正愿意去赌100倍的赌徒
能够有钱
然后换成U进入这个市场
你要对美股的影响
就是币圈 simply太小了
还是没有影响
那么你就币圈这个市场
要真正回得来的话
就是说我们身上我也回得来
我认为币圈现在基本上走了一个熊市
因为你可以看到
所有的小币的funding大部分全是负的
这种情况下
跟二一年完全不一样
不是一个真正优势
你不能说比特币在涨
比特币涨的逻辑
我之前也讲过了
很多时候它是
它信货期货的一个差
不同不等效的影响到这的
就大家买了ETF
100多亿买了ETF
然后去做空凛ACM的期货
但是这个中间的差价
又是可能是各大中情化交易所
包括BN他们给的
但是你要真正让这些投资人
全部进入到币圈那些小币的投资
那你需要很多中国人借了消费带
然后换成U进去才行
做币圈的山寨币的投资人
至实之中
都是中国人
都是国人在那里赌
或者是韩国人
中国人韩国人
这帮亚洲人在那里赌
我现在没有看到这个趋势
所以我过来总结一下
我觉得稳定币对于宏观市场影响
失灵
但是稳定币确实是一个
很好的支付的手段
大家可能会增加美元的影响力
特别在
比方说本来大家要用美元
现在结会不方便
或者是外汇控制的国家
这些东西都会增加美元的影响力
对美国肯定是好事
但是对于宏观来说短期的影响
很小很小
然后稳定币这个东西
对于社会的影响
它就是一个货币市场基金
对于币圈
资金会不会大规模进来
我觉得现在就稳定币反而看
我们有看到
包括RW里面有很多的钱
我进来了
好吧
好
我要不今天时间有点长了
我就先说到这里
好吗
好
那我谢谢大家时间
拜拜